hey guys and welcome back to the Jenna
and Julian podcast high five
it's hot out Julian literally sweating
right now yeah it's hot I hope you can't
see my sweat i Kinsey is this hot-ass
podcast is brought to you by Squarespace
Squarespace comm is one of the easiest
ways to build some of the best looking
websites out there you can build your
own website your own blog online store
professional person whatever you want
it's at squarespace.com start a free
trial no credit card needed we will get
to more of that later but yeah it's it's
hot today I think you got it to like 98
live mm-hmm I think so I don't know yeah
I didn't look at my watch all day to
check the temperature
oh your Apple watch a lot so check this
out just because you guys forgot we have
Apple watch's alpha iyi watch and these
Dale mugs were given to me at one of my
live shows and they're awesome [ __ ] you
Dale [ __ ] you dad who says Dale on them
do deal [ __ ] you Dale [ __ ] do you know
appropriate uh we uh I'm like I'm trying
to think right now I'm like why is it so
hot in the house it's nighttime it
should be illegal but it's not the heat
light gets trapped in the house it feels
cool in here during the day and then at
night it does feel very hot as houses
are no you're right you just step
outside and it's like nice and cool yeah
look well yeah look when I was a kid I
used to like lay on the ground like at
night and stuff cuz it was hot I might
do that tonight feels cold yeah I mean
or you dig yourself a hole in the yard
and then lay in it well you know I did
that last night and I just I really like
it cuz there were too many like no
records hmm
anyway today we wanted to do a part two
of a podcast we had done previously
called conspiracy theories you guys like
that one so we want these to be funny
though yeah so we figured we would do a
part two yeah
a real part two of real conspiracy
theories some other times you guys
really like that but we got to do these
are [ __ ] hysterical just to part
three this is just part two but like in
our own way all right how's that work
fair enough fair enough fair enough
unfair enough this is unfair yeah we
wanted to get like funny with these um
so they're conspiracy it doesn't on the
internet though yeah no they're I mean
technically they are conspiracy theories
because people have conspired that
they're true I don't know but yeah so
these are we wanted to get we already
did we gathered around like what 10 15
different conspiracy theories that we
could talk about and laugh about and
that's what we're gonna do right now
watch that made me laugh really hard
though they're they're pretty funny
should we just came there yeah and also
if you're one of the people that
believes any of these conspiracy
theories I need you to state your case
for any of them because they're [ __ ]
hysterical yeah please do the comment
section in the last conspiracy theories
podcast was amazing cuz you guys like
know your [ __ ] he has named [ __ ] um okay
so let's start on one that's not really
that far-fetched okay Gary Busey is
actually Tupac that could be real well
how why
well his teeth could just be hiding two
box whole body mmm what his teeth are
huge they're like this size of saying
that Tupac Park is just like standing
behind his teeth so every time he opens
his mouth to packs like hey and then he
has like shuts is not well then who is
Gary Busey he's Gary Busey but he's he's
at housing Tupac oh oh I just I just
made my own so he's not [ __ ] he's not to
park he's the mothership for Tupac to
park is living inside Gary Busey's mouth
hmm
that's a real [ __ ] conspiracy theory
though that someone wrote on the
internet she's actually Tupac
yeah it's pretty good I can't even think
of like a plausible way to explain that
someone just wrote that yeah that was
just it was just there therefore true
yeah
Follow Me minions Gary Busey it's too
bad
oh man let's start a cult about it to do
it all right you got one there you only
gonna movie this one yeah you really cuz
you read it so okay so basically in the
winter of 2007 Canada
maybe a part of Canada but Canada had a
really cold winter and this is just
something I read on the internet didn't
research it it also might be entirely
false but they had a really cold winter
and the sap on the trees in Canada
weren't producing the right type of SAP
for maple syrup
so basically maple syrup companies just
threw a bunch of fake [ __ ] in there and
it was a giant conspiracy of how they
pretended that it was the real stuff but
it wasn't so Candace has like some
serious issues going on this is not a
joke like this is fake syrup so I
thought I would introduce that one it
was funny like your reading done list of
like assassinations like dance like
conspiracy aachen spiring to kill like
people in government and then Canada has
fake syrup so well I mean though by that
[ __ ] logic maybe happened one winter
where the trees weren't producing the
right amount of SAP but like arguably at
some point during every winter it gets
ridiculously cold yeah so why does all
maple syrup is just fake maple syrup and
gary busey is like helping produce the
fake stuff gary busey without gary busey
there would be no syrup in the entire
world he created he owns the patent to
the feet we just gonna connect all of
these together gary busey just Gary
Busey and Tupac's the taste tester for
all the syrup you make sure you listen
Gary Busey's mouth exactly that's
exactly right
I just like well because I grew up
pretty north like close to Canada and
I've never ever ever heard of it being
so cold that the trees can't produce
yeah like I said I did no research so
that might not even be a thing but you
know it was on the year like [ __ ]
pine trees I don't know maybe survival
for like brazilian food no no like it's
not to say this app was no good it's
just to say the sack was not Canadians
standard of syrup good hmm you know I
mean so they stole it from upstate New
York because what you're saying they're
not mmm Rochester when it's too cold in
Canada we got your staff needs confirmed
oh my god okay uh the Royal Family's
like all all of the royal families are
actually lizard people and I said this
you when you said that earlier yeah
there's
about there's there's lots of theories
about lizard people that they're
basically like an alien race living
amongst us yeah yeah but they like the
whole race of people okay so it's not
just what everybody's like is it just
anyone specific we're like both at like
15% I love it [ __ ] no it's not any
one specific it'll be anyone famous
- like politicians - so the royal
families would it be would be included
they'd be on par for the people that are
convinced that the lizard people I want
to know what that means the lizard
people like if they look exactly like a
human who are they lizard people okay
imagine like an alien right and it looks
like a lizard yeah and then put your
mind to some into some like men and
black [ __ ] well then they just like zip
up the human to human suit okay all
right so so there's that I got it well I
mean so there's wearing suits or they
have like the ability to disguise their
bodies you know I don't know that was
just some you know I don't cuz we're
hearing funny conspiracy theories
Lizzy Beasley a serious concern okay so
Prince William and Kate Middleton or
whatever if their lizard people right
and they have a lizard baby does it come
out lizard or deliverable this went to a
baby suit yes or the lizard
oh but I'm not wait
so either the lizard baby was born a
baby cuz lizard baby because they're
both lizards right I think that is a
beautiful is the Royal lizard okay when
they have sex do they take off their
people suits and [ __ ] as lizards no they
don't need to they just take off the
heads of the people suit and use their
lizard tongues for sex
that's disgusting it's realist okay but
this channel is it
timeout though back to the point if they
have a baby is it a human baby why would
it be human if they're both lizard of
course when you lose a baby and the
environment is not going to just
randomly turn into a human baby so then
they have to have like a hospital and
like a midwife and whoever on board oh
yeah they have everything in hell it's
look it's gonna come out lizard don't
freak out yeah chill out it's just a
pleasure
okay do you think that Kate took off her
her people suit and just was lizard the
day of her baby's birth can she give
birth through a people suit it doesn't
matter because it was behind closed
doors nobody knows it's never going to
be public knowledge when she poops does
she need a lizard again doors hmm only
the lizard people know that okay I
wonder what lizard poop looks like so
yeah lizard people poop hmm
I imagine that the best way to catch a
lizard person is to follow them into a
bathroom with nothing fit their people
to do you think they poop out of their
butt her that's why I just asked you I
feel like they have to take off their
people suit because you can't poop
through it what if what if lizard poop
lizard people poop was like it was like
transparent and it could migrate through
material and light and wait what what I
have no idea I wrong how about we just
agree to not agree or just like the
royal family is definitely lizard people
yes yeah okay definitely for sure what
duh duh if you're the queen is it really
those are so long she's gonna live
another hundred years [ __ ] lizard
people people watching from the UK right
now and be like oh I guess apparently
the Royal people are lizard people oh
sorry guys I'm gonna follow them to the
bathroom to see him take off their
people suit uh yeah if you do that just
leave in the comments below how we can
bail you out of jail for getting you
followed and arrested sorry yeah it's
kind of your fault though yeah alright
you want to move on can you go to me
luck yeah okay sure I said yeah uh
notorious b.i.g faked his death but when
he saw his post human plastic posthumous
sorry posthumous records like destroying
numbers and going crazy and doing really
well he knew he couldn't come out of
hiding because it would tarnish is
legend so instead he disguised himself
as Rick Ross so now he is now Rick Ross
and there is no Rick Ross it's just
biggie I feel like that's just like the
most racist conspiracy theory erases
like oh here's like a big black guy
rapper you know who I bet he is so this
is but yeah
oh my god I did not come up with this I
read it why did that what that one she
was a better shape Timur no well Rick
Ross is getting in shape
he's a lot of pairs he thought Paris
your Frost is like CrossFit
yeah but Rick Ross like he also know
where he's been in like no I know he's a
whole path first yeah or or is that
lizard past maybe it was a lizard acting
out Rick Ross's pass so he can intercept
exactly when biggie died and then take
over and then the lizard just goes away
I might say I'm also Gary Busey yeah
well too fussy Tupac's involved in net
whoa oh [ __ ] it's getting real as [ __ ]
god uh two blocks just buying the teeth
man oh my god um yeah I'm not as take
notes okay this is important I just want
to know I want to meet the person that
thought of that I want to meet all these
kids just sitting around like super
duper high and they were like you know
what man [ __ ] biggie is Rick Ross
like I'm not even high I'm coming up
with the fact that to buck is like 95%
sure behind Gary Busey teeth right now
yeah I mean I don't even know what I
would come up with his eyebrows Hyatts
well that's why he was so great on The
Apprentice you still haven't seen that
seasons I've seen highlights because you
showed me but I really want to see it
one of the most magical things I've ever
watched on television the season of The
Apprentice the Carrie of youtubers I
really want to see it I think it's
magical not only because Gary Busey is
you know hysterical um but uh he goes
beyond because he's Tupac as well well
if you that's the thing it's like when
you watch a movie and you're you you
read about it afterwards you're like oh
I didn't know about that so when you
watch it again you're like I'm gonna
look for this now so when we watch the
season again we're going to be between
yeah we're going to be looking I just
saw - but you see - a little Ted Becky's
goes to rock there's a little bit didn't
even just the way that Gary Busey will
talk about something in great detail
well yeah cuz readily because Tupac is a
brilliant Park and being behind the
teeth has strings days pulling you can
control the words of Gary Busey not
always but sometimes Gary Busey has like
a 50% control rate of his own
so I suppose doing matching whatever too
far is just like making him jump the
shark and say ridiculous [ __ ] just the
[ __ ] mouth oh good okay oh this
podcast I'm sorry alright the next one
is like you love this one too real for
me because I wear glasses in context
every single [ __ ] day of my life cuz
I'm too much of a [ __ ] to go get lazy
I'm terrified of I don't want to do it
it's not worth the investment at all my
god guys look terrifying yeah I don't
want no thank you
but this next conspiracy theory is that
contact cases keep getting bigger so you
need to keep buying more so like okay
first of all let's just imagine thang
okay the people like manufacturing these
contract cases are like alright it's
2014 let's do for one 14th of a
centimeter this were bigger and like are
they are they really profitable
is that like profitable that plan like
that much more solution you're going to
buy and what if people don't even fill
it to the top of solution you know what
I bet if they look done criticize
contact where came up with that I know
well well that and the fact that LASIK
and stuff exists like we gotta get our
money back - yeah we're losing lifetime
customers sure for sure it's [ __ ] up
what are they gonna do if people get
laser surgery and then they can't keep
selling contact solution they're gonna
run out of business they're gonna die
they're gonna have to go into the nasal
spray mystery or the mouth industry
which Gary Busey has on lock he is the
entire industry on his palm
should I say Tupac when we found that
though that I was so true though because
I feel like a few years ago even at
least like that long they seemed small
and now they just they do seem kind of
large contact cases although I've
switched to dailies the contacts these I
kept getting like eyeliner on my
contacts and then I'd have to live with
them for another two weeks it wouldn't
come off yeah people always like what's
on your eye and like ashes makeups been
there for a long time I can't get it off
because it was really contacts
terrifying yeah well if you try and Rob
it too hard then it rips marble marble
and then you go through your contacts
way too fast and I couldn't do that yeah
so
yes which daily so I no longer have to
put solution in a case yeah no I believe
you and everything you just said I just
have no way to relate to it because I've
literally never touched a contact so oh
sorry sorry
well sorry marble why is he barking um
it's I thought they were gonna be too
hot to bark this time true uh marble
marble you read the next one it's
fantastic novel quiet
Squarespace sponsor us alright the next
one oh the Mayans weren't in 2012 right
leading up to 2000 all the Mayans we're
not coming down to the end of the world
they were actually counting down to the
release of The Hobbit that's plausible
because it actually happened yeah no one
knew it but that's that was their secret
like party like guys it's the hobbits
coming out let's just say the world is
ending so people get on board and then
like the day before the Hobby came out
they were like look how many people are
as excited as we are that something is
going to happen tomorrow it's it's a
good thing that we made that calendar
like how many mines bought movie tickets
to The Hobbit on the day came out we
should find that box office under that's
public right no I just that is not
possible race you are
I'd like one adult and one my yeah
what's your race oh my god are you mine
alright we okay I don't care Julian's
not gonna look this up later
are you are you direct descendant of
someone that made a mind calendar like a
really long time ago
okay care about you everyone else go
into the theater it's the word mine
just sounded funny my in mine so you say
something a bunch of them my I'm gonna
tweet that no not it's like yours or is
it Mayan okay should I let it go let it
go you my inner see mine if any of you
get that reference which you will not if
I love you forever
the original quote is are you lying or
is he lying it's a quote from Billy
Madison you're like Oh Billy nice Billy
Madison right there on the there on the
front lawn
of the teacher who's also a wrestler and
he's controversy and he's getting kicked
out of whatever Hey so they're like
they're trying to figure out the truth
about this whole situation and the kid
who's like just an awful actor here so
he's like he has to determine if this
person's lying on the other person's
line he goes up to the guy he says are
you lying or is he lying and he
emphasizes the wrong word he emphasizes
like naughty aren't you lying or are you
like yeah he goes is he lying
oh god I don't know acted in the movie
though they didn't make it well that was
probably his best tank yes Shree Kali
said are you lying or is he something
like that are you lying or is he lying
are you lying or all right um enough
about Billy Madison why don't you read
the next one because I have no idea of
her mouth okay yeah I can tell because
it's spelled Tom it's well that's how
you spell to me right mm-hmm
that Marisa Tomei is Oscar was a mistake
that the person that presented her the
Oscar for her role in my cousin Vinnie
just read the envelope wrong and then
just didn't want to everyone's too
embarrassed to like fix it
it's like [ __ ] go with it if I can go
with it what I see Marissa told me but
who won if she you know you read the
theory I'm sure guys who won won ah have
you seen the movie my cousin Benny no I
mean it's silly and as I want to watch
it like in high school but it was
nothing that I'd be like damn she
deserves an Oscar yeah maybe that's
great [ __ ] I believe you okay that
theory sounds pretty like it could be
true it also says that Marissa Tomei
does not like that theory no she doesn't
she's not like that um do you want to
read the next one no go ahead alright so
the game the game the floor is lava you
know when you like can't touch the floor
because it's lava is actually bundled
into human DNA because how else could
every kid in every country in the world
play it at some point
that's the conspiracy I feel like it's
only natural to want to just like jump
around on things really it's built into
our DNA that's what you're made to think
because it's already in
inside of your DNA that's also public
yeah
no tag is instinctual unless it's dialed
into our DNA also what is it but wait
how do we know what what is instinctual
and what's not dial into our DNA mmm
eating sleeping definitely that's two
puffs sighs okay get your finger outta
my mouth no getting out of the mouth on
snow oh yeah well while we're on the
topic of fingers in your mouth why don't
we talk about our sponsor the card gets
really quickly it has nothing to do
think nothing to do it Squarespace com
is sponsoring the podcast Thank You
Squarespace thank ya Squarespace is for
those you don't know if you ever want to
create a website you go to Squarespace
comm and it literally lets you build the
website exactly how you like it it's the
easiest way to do it there's a ton of
templates all over the template all the
templates look absolutely professional
they look elegant I mean if you're
trying to do an online store if you're
trying to do a professional website for
your business your personal website
whatever it is
Squarespace will make it look absolutely
nice on a website weave on that personal
website hit me with that HTML but you
have you have to do no coding you have
to do nothing that you used to have to
do when you're writing a blog or website
you know years ago when is there a blow
we [ __ ] how to do that [ __ ] miserable
but no Squarespace is great they have
24/7 customer support they have web
sites all their web sites work perfectly
on mobile platforms so iPhones will have
the easy time using your website
completely customizable every website
you make comes with a free online store
built into it and I did say 24/7
customer support so I would I would say
that's a great huge selling point um so
yeah check it out Squarespace comm you
can start free trial no credit card
needed or if you would like to do the
website thing and get 10% off you can
use product code jayjay at checkout for
10% off of your website Squarespace comm
and if you don't have a website go make
a website make a website even if it's
about to wear that as furs to do is
about to buck trip being behind people's
teeth just Gary Busey's well that's
that's where it I think I might disagree
with you I think Gary Busey is the front
for where Tupac might just run his
entire
he might have little minions that tall
in other people's mouths hmm
yeah okay so the next one that you had
this that the The Fresh Prince of
bel-air the television show is actually
about death that will is dead
it will Smith Will Smith in the show is
dead and bel-air is heaven
uncle fellas God and Carlson is his
guide guide our conscience like a boom
you can interchange you wrote here that
bel-air apparently means beautiful sky
yeah what yeah what I don't read it
online maybe you guys can tell bel-air
what is maybe it translates in Mayan I
mean yeah definitely my inversion is
that what to PAC's book did he speak
Mayans probably my head's hurting okay
no it's better now yeah so and there was
also a couple motifs that people had
said like the taxi driver was death
because he was always talking about
things that related to maybe being dead
I don't know that's that's it The Fresh
Prince of bel-air is about being dead in
heaven
that's ridiculous
no it's not dying down along uh what
about his sisters who are they there's a
whole post on it I think what about the
mom ah there's there's a whole post in
what's the significance in the world to
dance tell us now Julian
alright you know what I'm gonna google
it on site go go for it hurry up lose my
patience
I need to know exactly what this person
says the significance of the Carlton
dances mm-hmm okay because why would his
guide do that uh all right let's see
meeting God solutely with Uncle Phil you
guys want to take it to the rabbit hole
we're going around um let's see the
distance from Hollywood to Bill here is
26 76 miles
or for 306 kilometers today that cab
ride would cost eight thousand three
hundred fifty six dollars ninety six
cents which is a lot of money and we'll
probably didn't pay weight because Maxie
driver was gone okay so this is saying
the taxi driver was God Uncle Phil what
but how is it twenty six miles from
Hollywood to bel-air Julian you're born
and raised here wait what
look it says it right there what is this
what is two thousand six hundred seventy
six miles yeah I said twenty six seventy
six miles
is that right that's not right ha Julian
Blair's here yes
oops sorry that's a bad website I'm not
even checking right now just oh my god
okay here we go
their major beautiful sky hole uncle in
this theory says two thousand miles away
I know I'm sorry
[ __ ] that was a bad website okay yeah
there's not that much anyways moving on
oh wait hold on oh here we go
God takes him to heaven where he lives
in a mansion with his wealthy aunt and
uncle and slowly works out his issues
and hardships that's just a show buddy
that's not any suggestion that's just
what happened so the taxes godthe yeah
no no Uncle Phil Scott I don't like that
theory that website was bad let's move
on I can't sorry about that
alright the government tells us not to
look directly at the Sun to prevent us
from gaining super powers that's
definitely real I think that that's real
I would always look at the Sun as a kid
and then like I would be blind but I
would run really really fast and I'll be
like why am i running so fast maybe you
thought you're going so fast because you
couldn't see well my brother saw me but
he was always inside so maybe no one was
running faster um
don't look at this son hello it's like
the government tells us like when is the
government told you to not look at the
Sun you're just like oh yeah your mom
teachers they don't look at the Sun you
can what if your mom is the government
okay that and then Tupac's in her mouth
good
yeah we got a Fisher um so longi wait uh
Julia Solange Beyonce's sister Solange
Knowles heshes good Solanki I got we're
sitting on the couch I go Julian do you
know if any um I like I wanted to talk
about some celebrity conspiracy theories
because there's some funny ones out
there and I go do you know who Beyonce
is who's yeah ya know who she is but you
know Solange's is like yeah I know she
is who is she again why just I needed to
refresh her I know she is I just didn't
remember Yonsei sister and there
allegedly five years apart but there's
also a conspiracy theory that beyonce is
actually seven years older than she
claims to be which would make them 12
years apart so this theory is that the
lunch or so long each woman is actually
my this is a launch is Beyonce's
daughter and not her sister and her
parents raised so longi so that Beyonce
could pursue her career singing etc and
not how to that's problem I say it's
probably real right and they couldn't do
a day in DNA test because like I said
everything's protected their in-house no
one's gonna ever let that happen well
yeah I imagine though if you did a DNA
test the only rate you could like figure
out what's going on is if you had like
the paternity test
yeah I mean tech up well yeah that's
true you know what I mean oh and that's
not true I don't know sign a channel is
it Jenna no exactly like they have this
thing yes science DNA obviously yes no
yes right doc basically just go to some
long geek on sir and be on sponsor and
grab a hair off their head at times and
then just go to the doctor I mean yeah
do it tell us what's going on here do it
yeah do your job do you think that
Beyonce is seven years older than she
claims
how does she how does she claim to be I
don't know X 30 Adam ten I can't
remember thirty ten I can't remember
yeah like I wouldn't doubt it I mean I
know these people like with all the
money in the world
how to make themselves look years
younger than they are so my that would
be looking crazy
what if so long e is actually Beyonce's
daughter and then Blue Ivy the other
conspiracy conspiracy is that Blue Ivy
is not Beyonce's daughter hmm that's her
granddaughter oh so long his daughter so
long D already has the daughter cuz the
long guy got pregnant what ifs along
these alleged daughter is so long G
sister hmm
and then Blue Ivy is solanki sister's
daughter and then everything just makes
sense well now well now and then Tupac
mm-hmm
all right RadioShack is actually a
money-laundering business for larger
companies I think this is true well yeah
not true RadioShack isn't a business
nobody shops that [ __ ]
RadioShack no way in [ __ ] hell if you
said yeah I got a go to Radio Shack I do
not trust you as a person yeah you're
going to pick up money from your giant
corporation that hides their money
through radio show exactly basically
yeah nothing that you could ever want
huh yeah literally nothing [ __ ] hey
RadioShack and why is the TV on I don't
know um okay this is racist that's it
it's just racist okay I'm gonna say it
anyway because it's it's a funny theory
it's fun it's not funny because it's
angry and racist it's just a funny
theory so don't don't kill me but the
pitch works down I've just read this on
the internet the Chinese government
funds millions of citizens a year to
emigrate them to Western countries so
that they can drive slow and slow down
people from getting to work thus slowing
down those countries economies I mean I
mean it's thing hinges on the stereotype
that Asians are badger or Chinese people
are bad drivers right hinges hinges
hinges which we all know is not true at
all but sometimes cages just as much as
white peope anyone can be a bad driver
I've seen bad Chinese drivers I've seen
bad American drivers I've seen bad dog
drivers I mean everyone is funny if you
bought into that stereotype I think
that's a very funny [ __ ] thought so
so if you were to be like really
and racist it's funny I'm just kidding
as a kid um it's not race
can I read the next is the idea of a
government like spending over guys guys
guys get out go going Drive [ __ ] slow
what if they just drives off all day
they don't do anything with Drive that's
what they do well they have to really
just pay them to like live in some house
what what all live in one house but if
millions of citizens but ya mean is it a
clown house they just all say no because
they live in different cities but maybe
like in each house it's like at the top
of like at Target or something so they
could park you know where it's at the
top of a Circuit City oh good one but
like you know when you go somewhere
really late at night in a parking garage
and you're like what are all these cars
doing here and then there's no one in
the store it's cuz they always know
driving cars they all live there oh my
god
they're also all the ones that bought
tickets to The Hobbit or whatever 20 so
they're also Mayan yeah are they're the
people that the Mayans recruited by
brainwash true ma'am can you imagine a
government sitting down low be like what
can we do we should stop them their
government is doing to our economy is so
fast and booming let's slow it down
literally physically slowing them down
alright that's [ __ ] sofa
alright my next business was really good
have you read this next one yeah okay
rocks are actually soft and squishy they
just tense up when you pick them up or
get her touch of them it's not the worst
theory it could be like cornstarch I
feel like there's no disproving that
ever because if you're ever gonna test
it you're touching it in there tensing
up their nerve that's not true you could
test it like for its volume like there's
lots of no no this isn't science Jenna
this isn't science just you think
there's no logic here come on yeah yeah
like anytime you were to test it whether
in a lab or with a tool or measuring it
or whatever it is it would tense up
because it's being touched by something
okay but what about someone don't touch
me grandpa
in if it's really squishy and no one's
touching it how does it hold its shape
it doesn't mean not solid it's a solid
state but it's like just squishy just
squish it it's like if it was giant a
giant jello thing I want to take a bite
out of it but then it's gonna tense up
what if oh god here we go
what if every time you take a bite out
of it what are the only pies that you
could take out of rocks are used by Gary
Busey's teeth because they're big and
strong enough and that is the only thing
that would break through the tensed up
exterior of the rock to get to the
switch squishy wonderful center of the
rock aside from salon Soleimani
so long he's like she's got a lot of
stuff going on he's a wizard
solanki is the name of wizard would have
so now you want to Glasson I have
another one after this now Lady Gaga is
one of Sacha Baron Cohen's character yes
that's a really good one
I got nothing on that that's just
probably true okay this this other one
that I found was that Nicki Minaj is not
like a good rapper at all and she can't
rap aside from there's tons of all these
theories about people like being
vampires they never died and they've
been around for millions of years
because they'll finally get an old
picture that looks like so or that
they're time travelers but this one had
nothing to do with that it just had to
do the fact that Nicki Minaj actually
can't rap at all
and so instead someone slowed down this
version of Super Bass and it sounds
exactly according to this person like
jay-z
alright don't put it too close okay so
that Nicki Minaj doesn't really rap but
they just speed up - jay-z rapping is it
like legit does it sound
it's pretty funny probably I am you can
swipe up we've all told once she goes to
settings doesn't offer Wi-Fi while you
swipe up and hit watch it business
mind your business it's all of our
business now because we will be watching
jay-z was not working
oh is it going to my headphones no you
know I'm grabbing flutes we have
grab grab grab well why is not working
now this podcast brought to you by me
not knowing how to use the phone oh my
god that face is terrifying yeah it's
awesome it's just like a warping slow
motion picture of Nicki Minaj's
is poor is it Nicki Minaj wait why is it
not working
wait what mmm what what what
anyway um why don't you just have you
got and I'll put it in post so here it
is you guys want to listen Oh what are
you gonna google it uh yeah okay well
let me just do a little bit about
Squarespace then since you're doing that
last thing I'm gonna mention about
Squarespace like I said before you don't
need a credit card if you want to just
test it out you're not required to put
your credit card in you can go to
Squarespace calm and just click free
trial try your website try the tools see
the templates see what they got and if
you like it and you get 10% off your
website 10% off that's pretty good
considering all you did was just watch a
podcast and you know we appreciate you
guys supporting the podcast we
appreciate Squarespace supporting the
podcast thank you
Jesus jay-z is weird but thank you
Squarespace for supporting us thank you
guys for being mindful and aware that we
you know get to do the podcast because
we are yeah this is a different one but
this is called jay-z is Nicki Minaj
jay-z Sveta
all right you're not here that it's it's
fast like Nicki Minaj know so that was
jay-z yes oh that was thank you for not
no I want to find that other one that
was funny that's crazy actually I was
like what's what's the deal it sounds
like Nicki Minaj whatever but it's
chasey this one is the opposite so this
is a Nicki Minaj song slowed down but
now it sounds like Jase yeah face
morphing you can find these on YouTube
but sounds like jay-z it doesn't just
sound like any rapper it sounds like him
he is the same boy okay this is scary
this is Nicki is it slow down okay I am
absolutely freaked out let something get
jay-z wasn't driving he's talking to her
go alright buy into it I don't want to
hear the chorus
that's scary [ __ ] dude all right guys
here under the door beauty queen anyway
by that by that no that is scary did you
get what about like her speaking voice
though it sounds and she just makes her
bassington yeah I don't know it's hard
to think about I don't know I personally
don't think she's good that is pretty
cool though right yeah that is cool I
hope that I was like weird how that this
podcast ended with like a legit [ __ ]
conspiracy because I that's I mean
believe it or not that sounded like
jay-z I'm sorry it sounds yeah but it's
also because they have New York accents
like it sounded like jay-z didn't do
sound like another guy with New York
accent sound like jay-z so either they
are conspiring to talk like each other
in their own planet that's so ridiculous
that they can't even like jay-z can't
write it first of all she's with Lil
Wayne and not jay-z Young Money right
yeah but like jay-z can't just like
write it in hand loominatee comfy nice
he'll sit right here he needs to record
it and then that's it laughing doesn't
she listen
yeah she probably dubs a little bit over
it but no that's it yeah anyways beats
by Nicki Minaj
beats way too far o beats by Gary Busey
yeah you guys about Gary piece is really
[ __ ] podcast but we enjoy doing it
alright psyche that was fun we can do a
part three of conspiracy theories but
more serious so you guys want I feel
like we should do that yeah but we
wanted to do some I was like we should
do conspiracy theories part two and then
I looked up one and she was laughs
laughs I really
why we make it funny so um yeah I hope
you guys enjoyed this funny podcast that
it was pretty good beef but uh thanks
for remembering the government doesn't
like you look at the Sun because they
don't want you to gain super cut yeah I
actually go outside right now and check
out the Sun because you'll probably get
a little faster than wherever you're
going you might run into [ __ ] but it's
alright
check out squarespace.com and run sound
sideways i will be back next Monday with
a podcast
probably a little less good eyes now
when a sense I'm jay-z or to pucker my
earth yeah it's laggy so long a brain
exploding country see you guys